- Hey everyone, how are you?
- [Audience] Good.
- Thanks for having me,
can I answer any questions?
Actually, how
many people here have
no idea who I am,
raise your hand?
Shit, okay.
(audience laughter)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Too Fast" by Sonder)
Heading out of Utah,
good talk this morning,
a lot of energy.
You know how many people
here want to build a business
or a personal brand so
they can buy stuff with it?
Like, you know, that
thing I said the other day
on the vlog, I don't
want to buy a private jet
like everybody tells me to do
when they see that I'm wasting
an hour on an
extra commercial flight,
because I want to
buy the New York Jets,
you know what I mean?
(audience applause)
And so, all this
behavior, my man,
is predicated on insecurity.
You know why 24 year old dudes
buy watches, 'cause
they're not confident
and they need
that to get a girl.
(audience laughter)
Like all those dudes
that are flashing on
social media, I look at them,
I'm like, insecure,
like, not real confident.
Puffed up fake, so
it's the same old thing,
it's the same reason
people buy followers on social,
guys, and some of you did
it, 'cause one of the people
I looked at last
night that's here
with the hashtag bought it,
you know how I know?
You can't have
800,000 followers on Instagram
and get 27
comments and 94 likes.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
I ended my talk with it,
which is the worst business
is to sell to losers,
and I promise you,
there's a stunning
amount of people here
who try to sell to
the bottom feeders.
And you never trick winners.
When people DM me and
they're like, "Yo GaryVee,
"check me out, I'm killing
it, and they've got 900,000
"followers on Instagram," but
they don't actually have it,
I reply, "No, you aren't."
And then their
feelings are hurt.
(audience laughter) And
it makes me feel awesome.
(audience laughter)
Hold your breath,
keep building for the
audience, bring them value.
You know what your next
Instagram post should be
instead of taking
$400 for a sponsored ad?
Why can't your
next Instagram post be,
what can I do for you guys
to make this account better?
And then read all the
comments, and then act on 'em.
Got it.
(audience applause)
Different kind of vibe too.
I'm on a weird roll,
taking different vibes.
Stop hiring more
services, coaches, people,
all which are disguises for you
not to actually do the work.
(audience cheers)
Lot of admiration,
a lot of love, lot of selfies.
("Too Fast) by Sonder)
Really interesting moment
right now, as you guys know
from the CFO episode,
there's a lot going on,
very deep in my
business, a lot of new business
we're winning, just a
great day in my email.
The whole Vayner
Daily Digital Deep Dive.
Daily digital deep dive,
daily digital deep dive.
So many of you come
into VaynerMedia spending,
I mean, it's just
so exciting, nice,
having 10 hours at VaynerMedia
with all of the practitioners
in culture, strategy,
paid media, and
so that's been fun.
We've sold a bunch of
seats, first day sold out,
second day is about to sell out.
So that's going well,
nice new business unit for us.
And huge for you, what else?
Just a lot of content.
I think people are
too crippled by content.
I call it the 14-year-old
teenage move,
which is, so many 14
year olds post on Instagram
and then if they don't
get enough likes right away
they take it down. There
are literally 14-year-old
teenage girls that take an hour
and a half to take a selfie
because they put it up
seven times until there
is actual engagement,
they keep taking it down.
And the truth is, we
all say yep, yep, yep,
and yet you're doing it as well.
You're overthinking your
content, like think about,
again, eating my own dog food,
I believe that all content
is valuable one way or the
other, or it may or may not
be valuable, every person
here has put up something
on the internet that has done
better than they thought it
would, and that has done worse
than they thought it would.
Why should you test it?
It's much faster to
just keep putting it out.
Like all the
thought of testing it,
and let me overthink it, why?
Everybody thinks
they're gonna put out a piece
of content
that's gonna hurt you?
What is it gonna do?
It's not gonna get
as many likes as you like?
Again, way too much ego and
insecurity driving decisions.
Let the chips
fall where they are,
just put out fucking content.
Cool, that's a
good way, I'm out.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
Bye guys, take care.
(audience cheers and applause)
Taylor's mom
emailed us, which is insane.
A lot of offers,
just a lot going on.
Planet of the Apps, my TV
show, just saw the media play,
that's gonna be insane.
You're gonna be seeing
a whole lot of this
face in its different forms.
My neck, fixing my neck, got
this new awesome T-shirt,
right, tortoise in a
hare's costume, that's me,
I seem fast, and I am, I'm
micro fast, but I'm macro slow.
- [Man] You killed it today.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Man] These are a bunch of,--
- [Gary] Oh,
am I coming to say hello?
Got it.
What's the score?
- So we'd like to
welcome to the stage here
Gary Vaynerchuk, and
appreciate him taking time
to be here, and without
a whole lot of introduction
I'm just gonna hand him
the mic and let him rip.
Thanks Gary.
- Okay, no worries.
Hey everyone, how are you?
- [Audience] Good.
- Thanks for having me.
Can I answer any questions?
Actually, how many
people here have no idea
who I am, raise your hand?
Shit, okay.
When you incentivize
somebody to do something
that is predicated on rewarding
them with something else,
you're not actually
getting the natural action.
I hate it, I hate like, watch
this video or play this game
and you'll get 5,000 points,
and then you get a
fuckin' iPad, horse shit.
(audience laughter)
Don't like it, they all
lose, they all have a run,
somebody exits, 'cause whatever,
but 9 out of 10
of them lose every time
'cause you're
forcing behavior instead
of reacting to behavior, got it?
Alright, see you.
(audience applause)
I continue to build my brand
more than any other reason,
and there's a lot of
vanity that comes with it,
there's a lot of financial
aspects that come along with it,
but I want everybody to
know, and again, my behavior
has proven this, 'cause I
did it before this happened,
the single biggest
reason I continue to build
my personal brand is it
forces me every single day
to use Instagram,
SnapChat, Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube, Tumblr, it
forces me, and then I become
the plumber, not
just the architect.
And there's way too
many architects in here,
and there's way too
many plumbers in here,
and there's not enough
of people that are both.
- 2030, 2040,
I live for the year 2040.
I'm not counting my chickens,
I'm not reading my headlines.
I'm not even incorporating this
admiration that I'm getting
right now. I'm zero,
I'm nothing, I'm fucking dirt.
I haven't started, I'm a kid.
("Too Fast" by Sonder)